mika puede comer 21 tacos en 66 minutos
ella quiere saber cuántos minutos m se
tardaría en comer 35 tacos si pueden
mantener el mismo ritmo entonces una
gran pista en este problema es mantener
el mismo ritmo eso quiere decir que los
tacos que come por minuto entonces
describo tacos por minuto esta razón
siempre se mantiene igual siempre igual
será constante es decir siempre se
mantiene el mismo ritmo entonces si se
nos está diciendo que mica puede comer
21 tacos en 66 minutos así que lo
escribo entonces nica ella puede comer
21 tacos en 66 minutos y si el ritmo en
el que mica come sus tacos siempre se
mantiene igual entonces esta razón será
la razón entre 35 tacos
y el tiempo que mika tarde en comer esos
35 tacos así que 35 / m que serían los
minutos que tarda mica en comer 35 tacos
entonces una vez más tenemos aquí tacos
por minuto los tacos que come cada
minuto debe ser constante porque porque
el mismo ritmo en el que come los tacos
siempre se mantiene igual es el mismo
ritmo entonces si me cae como 21 tacos
en 66 minutos
quiere decir que come 35 tacos nm
minutos estas razones serán iguales
porque estamos trabajando con una
relación proporcional y entonces ahora
ya tenemos esta situación donde tenemos
una ecuación y hay que resolver para m
así que hagamos eso entonces tenemos
esta ecuación y tenemos a la m en el
denominador no me gusta la m en el
denominador así que multiplicó ambos
lados de esta ecuación por m
y que obtenemos veamos del lado
izquierdo tenemos 21 entre 66 por m 21
entre 66 por m por m esto es igual
tenemos 35 sobre m por m la semen se
cancelan y nos queda 35 ahora solo hay
que resolver para m
hay que multiplicar ambos lados de la
ecuación por el recíproco del
coeficiente de n entonces multiplico
ambos lados por 66 entre 21 simplemente
voltear el numerador y el denominador
ese es el recíproco y si multiplico un
lado por el recíproco también tengo que
multiplicar este lado para que se
mantenga la igualdad de la ecuación
entonces esto esto es igual a 1 pues sí
estoy multiplicando algo por su
recíproco te va a quedar 1
entonces me queda m es igual
ver 35 x 66 entre 21 eso a que es igual
bueno
el 35 eso eso es lo mismo que 5 por 7
que 5 por 7 y el 21 es lo mismo que 3
por 7 3 por 7 21 así que el 21 es lo
mismo que 3 por 7 como puedes ver estás
multiplicando por 7 y estás dividiendo
entre 7 tenemos a este 7 en el
denominador así que los 7 se cancelan
por lo tanto esto se simplifica a 5 por
66 entre 3 y esto lo podemos simplificar
aún más porque el 66
es lo mismo que 3 por 22 3 por 22 y 66
así que esto es lo mismo que 3 por 22
entonces tienes un 3 en el numerador y
un 3 en el denominador 3 entre 3 eso es
igual a 1 se cancelan así que los
cancelamos los 3
y nos queda 5 por 22 5 por 22 es igual a
así que m es igual a 110 por lo tanto le
tomaría a mika en minutos es decir 110
minutos para comer 35 tacos si es que mi
casa sigue comiendo al mismo ritmo le
tomaría 110 minutos comer 35 tacos ahora
si lo intentaste hacer por tu cuenta tal
vez obtuviste una ecuación distinta a la
que yo obtuve tal vez en lugar de pensar
en tacos por minuto como yo lo hice tú
pensaste en minutos por taco y en esa
situación si pensaste en el término de
minutos por taco entonces tendrías que
mika se tardó 66 minutos en comer 21
tacos y le va a tomar a mika m minutos
comer 35 tacos así que le va a tomar a
mika m minutos en comer 35 tacos si el
mismo ritmo se mantiene entonces estas
dos razones serán iguales porque el
mismo ritmo se mantiene
ahora ya podemos resolver para m de
hecho así es más fácil resolver para m
solo hay que multiplicar ambos lados de
esta ecuación por 35 entonces
multiplicamos el lado derecho por 35 y
multiplicamos el lado izquierdo por 35
para que se mantenga la igualdad en la
ecuación y del lado del lado derecho se
cancelan los 35 y nos queda m del lado
izquierdo tienes 35 x 66 entre 21 ya
sabemos que eso es igual a 110 así que
110 es igual a m y una vez más hay
muchas maneras de resolver esto pero
obtuvimos la misma respuesta como puedes
ver m es igual a 110